South African conservationists say
they're waging a war against poachers
and Anton mzimba was one of the many
Park Rangers on the front line he
dedicated his career to protecting
Wildlife it's very painful to see how
cruel people are it was Anton's success
as head Ranger at Timber Valley private
nature reserve for more than two decades
that cost him his life for months and
years Anton had been targeted receiving
death threats his family was receiving
threats his team was receiving threats
he was under a huge amount of pressure
Matt lindenberg was making a documentary
about Anton titled Rhino man but in July
before it was released his friend was
fatally shot
three men approached Anton's home under
the guise of needing water for their
vehicle they took weapons out and
unloaded on him
and in the process injured his wife and
also I think the most devastating thing
just to show how violent this
this war and poaching is is they took
shots at his children Anton leaves
behind seven children his wife survived
the attack I saw the blood I saw how he
was shot I saw the kids
it was just it was just
difficult it was too much Anton's cousin
Leyton Cabela is also a park ranger with
the all-female group The Black Mambas
she knows every time she puts on her
boots she's walking into Danger
it's not easy to wake up every day go
out on patrol
I'm doing this for him I'm doing this
for his legacy
the numbers of rhinos in Kruger National
Park have declined so much that poachers
are now turning their attention to
private reserves and it's up to those
landowners to foot the bill for extra
security measures to protect these
animals the same animals the government
promotes as one of its greatest tourist
attractions okay Reserve owner Derek
leverton supplies his ranges with body
armor and night vision goggles to help
keep them safe what these syndicates
will do to families to get their hands
on horn is frightening he's also applied
for a gun license
the teams that come poach they'll bring
one gun for the Rhinos they'll bring two
guns for us
it is very risky no arrests have been
made in connection with Anton's murder
as well as Wildlife Anton also had a
passion for teaching young people about
conservation she said you know if our
children if my children don't see the
value the beauty if they don't even have
empathy care compassion understanding
for wildlife how can I expect them to
protect that Wildlife Matt is helping to
continue Anton's Legacy and while the
film's ending has changed its message
has not
Emily anguin Al Jazeera Hood Sprite
South Africa